this is a production of cornell
university
welcome everyone uh to the second in our
series of webinars
that are part of a larger project that
the turfgrass science program
here at cornell is involved with
um that's based at the rochester
institute of technology and this is a a
state-funded
part of
new york state's uh dec programs
throughout the state and it's the
pollution prevention institute many of
you know we had the
water webinar uh justice just just a few
weeks ago
um this is the nutrient management and
we'll have a pesticide
uh and a um water quality one after the
fat uh pesticide and pest
mm-hmm yeah
solution one as well yeah and point
source pollution sorry that's the one
i'm missing anyway uh it's it's um this
as part of a larger project many of you
know may know from paying attention to
it it was a a very intentional approach
of um surveying a section of our
industry at a western central in finger
lakes new york um
that
uh identified particular aspects of
water quality protection as we define
them using best management practices
that were being adopted
and so there there's the slide where we
have evaluated adoption we know where
we're weak and we're developing ways of
improving that adoption through a
variety of
projects that include webinars
publications videos brief assistance
projects direct assistance projects that
you'll hear more about over the uh
coming year and so
this is part of our efforts to
make people more aware about aspects of
nutrient management that fit into this
overall adoption scheme we're devising
with our pal rick slattery the former
superintendent at locust hill country
club
um
and now it's my pleasure to invite my uh
colleague carl scamenti to take us
through this very important part that i
think everyone's going to be very
impressed with the progressive way in
which we're beginning to think about
this not just for water quality but for
also you know
playability and management of the golf
course with less resources and less
labor
so carl it's uh uh let's take us through
this process and then we'll rejoin you
at the end here to have some questions
and answers perfect thanks frank um yeah
so as you said we're going to focus on
the nutrient management part portion of
this project right we have these four
categories
that we collected survey data on
and i think a good place to start is
just to look at the data
and similar in our water management
webinar we talked with rick and we
looked through the data we saw some bmps
we do really well and also maybe some
bmps we're not so good at so as you can
see here
on the right is our adoption rate
obviously higher is better
and there are several categories we do
really well in
written fertilizer applications so
keeping records of our fertilizer
applications during the year we do well
at that
calibrating equipment right more than 75
percent of us do that that's good we
might want to see that higher but still
overall good adoption there
avoiding applying
fertilizer in the rough areas so a lot
of times we talk about roughs they're
usually the closest to water bodies
they're a large acreage require a lot of
product if you are going to fertilize
them
only about 20 percent of golf courses do
fertilize rough
around our region we understand there's
quality
concerns right certain golf courses are
going to have quality expectations that
might affect whether they do that or not
of course we're sensitive to that but uh
overall we see um a lot of people are
avoiding
fertilizing rocks and a border avoiding
some runoff and nutrient concerns there
and then avoiding fertilizing after
october 15th we'll talk about the
science behind that today and why that's
probably not a good idea but again we do
really well avoiding fertilizer after
the turf grass has basically stopped
growing
um so those are some of the the bmps we
do really well at um and then of course
there's weak areas as frank mentioned
i think it's completely okay for us to
acknowledge that we don't do some things
really well that's the first step in uh
in creating the awareness and then
hopefully driving adoption
one of these ones over here only 26 of
us
measure or predict growth rate of our
turf grass
some of you may have heard that we can
do this and just haven't done it yet
some of you may not have heard that
again we'll go through today why that's
important and why i think more than 26
percent of us
should do that
um only about 30 of people consider soil
moisture when they're applying
fertilizer
what does that mean well if we have
saturated soils we're going to
want to avoid applying fertilizer then
right
only about 30 percent of us are flexible
enough in our
application regimen
to consider soil moisture and maybe move
applications around
only 24 of people apply phosphorus
according to mlsn guidelines mlsn
haven't heard that acronym before again
we're going to go over that today
basically that's a way to interpret soil
tests and apply phosphorus only when we
need it
and then finally one of the you know
bmps we don't do
well at the least adopted one is
documenting a nutrient management plan
this is one we had a lot of conversation
with superintendents about
i'll talk about kind of the barriers to
adoption of that specific bmp today and
hopefully we've created a resource
that'll make that super easy
and uh hopefully that will drive that
adoption rate up
so okay you know we see that variability
in bmp
some really well adapted some not well
adopted so we said is hey let's draw
some metaphors to golf and let's create
bmps and put them in sections par birdie
eagle right
uh and for us the pars the bmp pars
should be broadly applicable to every
golf course
they should be easily achievable right
maybe a little bit of effort here and
there but every golf course should be
able to do these parts they're the
low-hanging fruit
we think everybody should really
standardize those bmps and make those
uh necessary the birdies is that level
up right so now they're still broadly
applied to every golf course big or
small
but they take a little bit more effort
right maybe they take a small amount of
investment whether that's time labor
money
um and everybody can still do them
they're just going to take a little bit
more right
a little bit aspirational but still
within the reach of all golf courses and
then the eagles
you know the eagles are really
aspirational right not everybody is
going to be able to do every bmp these
are the ones that we understand hey you
might have constraints whether that's
economic or labor
certain sites may be able to do these
better than others
requiring more effort maybe a little bit
more investment
they have a longer term aspect to them
uh and they're more advanced so we kind
of stratified these bmps
and we put them in this infographic
poster and for those not familiar with
the project this is kind of our seminal
document that we want to tie everything
back to
this makes it all really simple creates
that awareness
and so today what i want to do is just
go through in our nutrient management
section go through these parberries and
eagles and kind of expand on these
thoughts and explain a little bit more
about them
in addition to that awareness that just
you might get from breediness
so the first par i want to talk about uh
kind of narrow pointing to it here
knowing your nutrient needs
and that just means soil testing
um so before we talk about
what we can gain from soil testing why
it's useful
i think it's good just to talk about how
you soil test
for people that haven't done it before
there's quite a few in our surveys that
haven't
basically what you need is a soil probe
and what you can start with is just a
couple greens a year so you can also do
these on tees or fairways it's most
common to do them on the greens because
that's the most
intensely managed surface on our golf
courses
and you don't have to do all your greens
every single year i would suggest if
you've got 18 holes
do six screens and make sure you have a
representative sample so that might mean
hey taking two of your worst screens
maybe those are shady areas low lying
areas
struggle with two of your best screens
and then two in between
that would be a good way to get a
representative sample
when you sample a green you're going to
go ahead and take eight to ten
subsamples what does a subsample mean
that's just one of these soil probes
right
over here about eight to ten of those
per grain based on the size
and you're going to make sure you have a
consistent sampling depth this is really
important you'll see
over here on this soil probe i have a
little strip of duct tape
now i sampled to four inches
i've seen three inches recommended as a
sampling depth
or the length of your root zone whatever
you choose it's just got to be
consistent every single time
i've got this strip of duct tape here
that every time i put that soil probe in
the ground it catches the grass right at
four inches so i know every sample i
take out
is is that depth
that's important because nutrient
concentrations can change as you go down
the soil so you see a little soil right
here
the the soil concentration of any
nutrient may be higher or lower up in
this
you know top one inch than it is say at
three to four inches
right so if you change that if you're
variable on your sampling depth it
creates variability in your samples
and the data becomes not as reliable so
consistent sampling death important and
same time of year again going back to
that consistency component
so
that's really basic soil chemical
testing you can look up a little bit
more on the process if you'd like
the bottom line you take your samples
you send them off to a lab and you get
something like this which is a matrix of
numbers usually in excel
and again if you're not familiar with
soil testing at all what do i do with
these numbers right are they good are
they bad
i don't know
you need a method to interpret those
results
and the simplest most science-backed way
to interpret those results in turf grass
are the minimum levels of sustainable
nutrition mlsn for short guidelines
um so there's other interpretation
methods out there
we
like the mlsn guidelines because they
were developed specifically for turf
grass
with thousands of samples
so the folks at pace turf and asian turf
grass center
spent years getting soil test results
from turf grass
looking at that data and developing
these these guidelines
and they're very simple simple to
interpret basically all you need is
enough
right so 37 parts per million if we're
looking here at potassium if your soil
test says 60
you're good to go if your soil test says
120 you're also good to go
120 and 60 not really any difference
there there's no optimum amount that's
the difference between this
interpretation method and some other
ones all you need is to be above 37
parts per million and they say you know
through their data that's plenty for the
turfgrass to have what it needs to grow
we're not farmers we're not trying to
grow yields here we're not trying to
grow as much as we can right so we don't
have an optimum we just need enough to
sustain healthy turf
and that's what makes these guidelines
really simple to interpret
really easy to understand
and they're backed by data
so okay why use the mlsn
one of the reasons is because of that
data-driven
methodology to develop them the other
reason is it's probably gonna
suggest you fertilize less than other
interpretation methods so
this is some data we got from
our work done at sunken meadow state
park helena chemical came in and they
mapped our soils using
an electromagnetic induction device
really cool device that helps us target
some
soil sampling
they generated a map of the soil
nutrient concentrations on every hole
the golf course 27 holes
worked with a professor at suny
farmingday nick menchik
and so they use that data that base data
and they interpret it using two
different
methods right so we have slan which is
another soil test interpretation method
and the mlsn we just talked about
so if we look at slant it says okay you
need 110 parts per million of potassium
they go through the hole
based on the nutrient concentrations
they calculated they recommend 560
pounds of potassium
so that's a good amount right that's
going to cost money it's going to have
time associated with it spreading that
fertilizer out there
using the same base data that same data
now just with the mlsn method which says
you only need 37 parts per million
oh look at that we need no potassium
needed to apply
and that soil testing method will say
hey your turf grass is still going to be
healthy
with that amount of potassium so that's
just an illustration there of of the
mlsn method and it typically will will
recommend less fertilizer
and that means saving you time and money
um and so this is what soil testing
looks like
over time
and i like this idea of trends uh
professor doug soldat
who talks a lot about soil testing will
say the same thing
looking at soil tests over time is
really what you want
to notice trends not necessarily the
short term kind of diagnostic tool but
more a
a long term his analogy is you know you
go to the doctor you get your blood
pressure every time and you just want to
be in a range right
and notice any trends over time so
this is one golf course one specific
uh you know we've got a couple years of
soil testing data here
and we notice trends right here's
phosphorus i've got the mlsn level right
here this course you use this course is
of course uses mlsn to fertilize
and as you can see in 2016 2017 they
were getting right at that phosphorus
mlsn level
he began to notice some purpling here
and there so they said okay you know
it's time for us to
apply some fertilizer get us just enough
above that level to be good for a couple
years and in fact that's what they're
doing
so that's one way
over the long term you can be
you can use this data notice trends you
might also use the ph sometimes they
give you an organic matter number as
well
if you've got some observations from
your golf course is it performing are
the greens performing well or not so
well
maybe you can start to dial in certain
things hey i noticed my golf course
got better when i went from 2019 to 2020
maybe you can start to notice things ph
or potassium levels they change
you can develop some site-specific kind
of mlsn levels for yourself
and so what we do at the cornell turf
grass research center we test every year
and we kind of look for symptoms of of
nutrient deficiencies and we won't apply
fertilizer unless we see something
like an uh for example a phosphorus
deficiency now over the years
you know we haven't applied much
phosphorus we haven't seen the purpling
that's associated with phosphorus
deficiency
uh the last time we tested for
phosphorus we got three parts per
million
uh the recommendation by mlsn is
actually 21 parts per million so
we're woefully deficient in phosphorus
yet we don't see any symptoms why is
that well the folks who produce the mlsn
guidelines actually built some safety
factors in there so those numbers are
actually a little higher than even they
could
they could recommend just for safety's
sake
even though they're lower than any other
soil testing interpretation out there so
you know for us our personal our site
specific mlsn might actually be lower
than the numbers you get and that's
actually pretty common for people who
use mls
so that's how you maybe you you begin to
soil test how you use the data track it
over time
one of our pars we think every golf
course should do annual soil testing
another one of our powers not don't
apply late and we're referring to
fertilizer here
traditional wisdom you know the theory
has always been hey a late season you
know late fall application of fertilizer
will help that spring green up right
and so
looking through some data from from the
folks at minnesota and wisconsin
recently did some studies looking at uh
fall fertilizer applications
mid-september late september october
timings november timings
what they said is uh hey november
applied nitrogen was essentially the
same as october when it comes to that
spring color and quality that we're
looking for right
so what they're saying is well whether
you apply it in november or you apply it
in early october
you're still going to get that same
amount of spring color and quality
but their conclusion was hey if you're
putting it down in november the grass is
growing less right it's colder it's
there's less sunlight
um what you're going to end up doing is
wasting that fertilizer right if the tr
if the grass isn't using it if it's not
growing in november that fertilizer's
got it's got to go somewhere and where
it's probably going to go is the water
right so
you're not getting any additional
benefits from spring coloring and green
up
but you're probably wasting that
fertilizer so the conclusion here is hey
why don't you do that fall fertilizer
earlier whether it's late september
early october at the latest mid-october
you're still going to get those spring
color benefits but you're not going to
be wasting that fertilizer
and letting it leach out into the
environment
so it's important to note here that
fall fertilizer is still important right
it's still important for that spring
green up and increased rooting we see a
lot more rooting
in the fall and just a little bit of
fertilizer can encourage that
but late being november being late
october we want to avoid applications of
fertilizer after that
another reason to avoid uh late
season fertilizer applications uh snow
mold pink snow mold so this is research
out of cornell that frank did with mary
thorn years ago
looking at various seasonal rates and
late season rates of nitrogen and
potassium
so i'm just going to block off the sets
here that there's basically a low medium
and high potassium rate for each one of
these blocks and in every little block
of three you'll see that the high
potassium rate
has more snow mold
and it gets worse as your seasonal
rates are higher right basically what
this is saying is hey those late season
applications especially when they have
some more potassium in them are going to
lead to more snow mold so another reason
to avoid those late season nitrogen
applications again every golf course can
do that we think that's a par
um finally
again i talked about this earlier we do
this pretty good but calibrating
application equipment
we get to talk to rick slattery our
colleague on this project former
superintendent
he's told us the um
really the importance of calibrating
all your application right at the start
and spring right before you get out
there let's make sure we're not
um having any mishaps spraying or
spreading stuff
and then doing another one maybe early
summer right so catch yourself halfway
through the season make sure do that
little check make sure everything is
going well
so probably two times a year calibrating
application equipment
is ideal
and then there's also this idea of
having checkpoints during the
application hopefully a lot of people do
this but
uh you know maybe when half your spray
tank should be used by you know hole
seven or whatever it may be
you know have that as a checkpoint when
you're going along have your applicator
get out and look out say okay yeah have
i used half my tank uh are we good to go
that way you don't spray the whole golf
course with uh with a nozzle off and a
streak down every fairway right
um so again there's a lot there's a lot
of uh resources on this i spent a lot of
time looking through different resources
just a couple here you could look at
from kentucky and penn state
there's videos there's documents that
will help you do this
so a lot of information out there if
you're not familiar with that
so just to review the pars right things
we think every golf course should do
soil testing
it's between 10 and 15 bucks for for one
soil sample submission so if you're
doing six screens it's under 100 bucks
to do that we think every golf course
can afford that
on an annual basis
we think that's a par using the mlsn
guidelines again
something we suggest to everybody these
late season fertilizer applications
avoiding those and calibrating equipment
so those are our pars uh now on to these
birdies right this next level
of uh nutrient management
first one we're gonna talk about is
growth uh and this is certainly an idea
that's taken off a little bit if um
you know if i'm reading the tea leaves
and seeing what superintendents are
doing a little bit more of these days
in tune more with the amount their grass
is growing
and this birdie version of this bmp is
just to start observing that right and
the best way to do that ask your
applicator or excuse me your mower in
the morning goes out in those greens
with buckets hey how many times did you
jump right if it's six times right okay
grass is growing a lot maybe i start
thinking about my fertilizer application
well i'm scheduled to go monday but he's
dumping six times every time he he mows
the greens do i need all that fertilizer
can i cut the rate do i need to
fertilize at all
um so
adjusting your fertilizer applications
based on the amounts of times the amount
times you're jumping you know it's a
good proxy for growth
if you want to do this for fairways this
is a great photo from
michael vesely right baylen hay on
fairways
you know get some observations from your
from your equipment operators is there a
ton of clipping clipping build up do i
need to fertilize those fairways here
soon
so the idea here is to get off of that
kind of schedule basis of fertilizer
and bring it back to growth right
because we care really about the growth
of the grass not what time in the season
we're in
so this is just some data that's kind of
outlining how variable a year can be
year to year
we've got 2020 last year here in blue
for ithaca
2021 we see very similar temperatures
the last two years almost identical
so we might think okay yeah temperature
is is related to growth so yeah i could
do the same thing i did last year right
well hold on a second we've also got
light levels right so we can look at
light right here in this middle graph
and we see that uh we were pretty
similar up until april and then wow we
really fell off a cliff with our light
levels in ithaca
this year um actually you know in until
july our light levels were basically
like a normal april
um so we think about grass right needs
light
photosynthesis to grow and
okay our light levels are really
different that's going to change how
much our grass is going right
similarly soil moisture right we've been
getting a lot more rain right it's been
cloudy overcast getting all these rainy
days that's why we have less light
it's why our storm moisture is higher so
again soil moisture contributes to
growth
we know
these are all things that affect growth
that are really independent of the date
right they vary year to year so it
doesn't make a whole lot of sense for us
to fertilize on a schedule it makes more
sense for us to fertilize
based on growth so just observing that
growth
we think is a birdie uh being flexible
with your fertilizer fertilizer
applications
um so another thing
relating to growth is traffic right and
i don't think we could find a better
picture
illustrating traffic for uh the year of
2020 than this it's a drone shot of the
16th hole at green lake state park um
you know 2020 the year of the single
cart rider
uh and you can really see that that cart
traffic right up the right hand side of
this whole
um and what we're looking at here is
it's obviously this this part of the
rough maybe this corner of the fairway
getting driven over a lot there's a lot
of traffic that's going to cause the
grass to grow less right so over here we
can see the stress on that grass while
over here on this left side of the hole
right not many people going over there
maybe a couple
but receiving substantially less traffic
um so what are we thinking about in this
area well
if single cart riders are going to be a
thing for the next three to five years
hey we might need some fertilizer in
this area right or else it's going to
end up like these you know these classic
kind of dirt patches that that happen a
lot of golf courses where there's just
concentrated traffic the turf grass
can't grow enough to sustain itself
ends up thinning out right and dying
so here what we're saying is hey we
should we should change our fertilizer
rates based on how much traffic there is
and this is an example right just a
visual example where we'd say hey maybe
throw some fertilizer here we don't need
it over here
but what if we use some data for this
uh we were really excited to do
a partner with the usga here and use
part of their deacon system
uh they have a gps golfer
tracker program where they essentially
send you little gps devices
we stood there on the first hole and
handed them out two golfers at our golf
course here at cornell
so the golfers would put them in their
pocket clip them under their belts
and every five second that gps would log
where that golfer was on the golf course
so over the course of 18 holes we could
generate what this is which is a heat
map of golfer data
where they spend the most time on the
golf course so quite literally data on
traffic of the golf course
and this is the sixth hole at cornell as
a dog like right par five
and really interesting to see the
traffic is centralized really on the
right side of this fairway
so we know most golfers are right-handed
most golfers slice
this is data that's uh confirming that
and really telling us exactly where they
slice it to right right near this bunker
into the rough but not so much on the
left part of this fairway right look at
how
how much less
traffic this left part of the fairway
receives compared to the right
so we're going back to growth and
fertilizing by growth and traffic these
things are interlinked
do we need the same amount of fertilizer
on the left side of this fairway as we
do on the right
i would say the answer is probably no
how you handle that is is tough right if
you have a gps sprayer and variable rate
technology we think you're good to go
you put this in there and you set it up
but
you know more practically maybe this is
something where you're skipping every
other application on the left side of
this fairway right it's going to grow
more it doesn't receive as much traffic
you know it doesn't need as much
fertilizer or maybe you bump up the
fertilizer rates and you get a passage
of the rough over here because it's
getting more traffic
um and you can even start extending this
into the greens right so more data the
12th hole here at cornell
you can see this front right portion of
the green heavily trafficked on the
ground we notice that's a pretty firm
area
it tends to thin out because there's
centralized traffic in there
um
so again we can we can move our
fertilizer rates around to address that
and so why do we care about this well
you know part of this is to create
consistency right i think we've all had
a golfer probably come up to us
um in your time as a superintendent who
says something like oh you know my balls
hit and released on this on the seventh
hole and then on the 13th hole it hit
and it spun back you know why can't the
firmness be the same or oh you know this
green is faster than that green
when we start moving these fertilizer
rates around to account for traffic
the idea is to create more consistency
in our playing surfaces so that's speed
that's firmness
that's accumulation of organic matter
right if everything's growing at about
the same rate it's not going to produce
organic matter at different rates you're
not going to get fatchy places here
where there's no traffic and thin places
where there's lots of traffic
so that's you know probably the primary
reason i would say you should start to
look at traffic and adjust fertilizer
rates accordingly
also unnecessary growth right we don't
really need the plant to grow a ton
again we're not farmers
we need to grow it the right amount and
when we have that unnecessary growth
it's pulling nutrients out of soil it's
pulling carbohydrate reserves out of the
plant making it less resilient for later
in the year maybe when
it needs it more
that unnecessary growth doesn't help us
out
so using this kind of traffic and
fertilizer combo
hopefully reduce some of that and that
also kind of translates into these
disease problems that are historically
associated with
you know high nitrogen or low nitrogen
we could also think of those as high
growth or low growth diseases
brown patch high high and
high growth disease typically on the
other end dollar spot anthracnose or
these low nitrogen could also be
considered to be low growth diseases
so again this is going to help us even
these things out and hopefully avoid
some of those issues
just a quick review right the birdies in
our nutrient management we're starting
to observe growth hopefully and observe
traffic
maybe make some changes in our program
in our management practices considering
these
variables
so now we get to the eagles right and
these are the things that
right it's going to start to require a
little bit more effort maybe some data
analysis we're going to put some data in
there at you
um a little bit more
analysis and effort on your part but i
think they're going to really make a
difference and they have for a lot of
people
the first eagle is measuring our growth
right now so
um a lot of people are doing this this
has been a trend in the last five years
that i've seen
measuring
we call it clipping volume right hashtag
clip fall on uh on twitter is what
you'll see
um pretty simple right we're mowing
grass off greens we're usually
collecting in buckets most people mow
greens with buckets
um that's great data if we just measure
that grass that's the exact amount we
grew in the last 24 hours it's right
there in our hands let's just measure it
right
so you dump it in a bucket
you measure it and you write it down
it's really simple it takes less than a
minute
and you do that every day um you know
wood bucket to do how to look at the
data you can go and micah woods has an
ebook he wrote a whole ebook on clipping
volume that's how important it is
i'd encourage you to go check it out but
at its core it's really just a very
simple process
um so now you're measuring instead of
kind of guessing right earlier that
birdie
um version of go by growth you're kind
of observing you're getting some some
feedback from your operators
that would be like the golf metaphor is
like uh kind of standing into approach
shot and you don't see a yardage marker
you're kind of just ballparking it like
ah it looks like 150 or it looks like
200.
once you start measuring clipping volume
here i'd say now we've got the
rangefinder version right measuring boom
167 boom 205 to the pin
um
it's a lot more accurate a lot more
precise
and it's going to be better data to go
off of
so your question okay well who's doing
this you know eric's doing it alan's
doing it
jamie rob lj we've got dogs do it and
apparently
um you know it just goes on and on i can
find a bunch of pictures from twitter
people doing it
and there's a lot of success stories
from this a lot of people finding this
to be a really valuable piece of data
that has helped them managing their
green surfaces
and as a matter of fact we've done it at
cornell
and this is a little case study we
started a couple years back with
superintendent dave hicks
so in 2018 i kind of peer pressured dave
into measuring clipping volume every
single day of the year
i'm on a couple greens this is data from
the fifth green
it's the first thing we kind of talked
about was okay we're going to measure
this data for a year what do i do with
it
and we said hey you know first year just
don't do anything with it just take it
and let's make some observations
let's note when the greens are good when
the greens are not so good
and at the end of the year we'll go and
look back and and see if we noticed any
trends
so you can see
in 2018 the orange line
it's a big swings in growth right so
what we notice with these swings in
growth
first of all is that they would happen
after really heavy rains right so all of
these spikes that i'm i'm having arrows
putting arrows at are one inch rains one
and a half inch two inch rains we got
some really big rain events there in
2018 so we get a rain event a couple
days afterwards we'd see the grass just
shoot out of the ground
right huge spikes in growth
and when that turned into is is
non-ideal plant conditions right so a
lot of grass growing what does that mean
it means slow grains soft greens
greens that change in quality throughout
the day very quickly right if they're
growing a lot in the morning they might
be okay but okay by noon they're they've
already slowed down by five o'clock
they're getting bumpy
so noticing that hey that high growth is
this is
way too high it produces bad plane
conditions
um but also during the year we we made
sure to make note of when the greens
were good
and it turns out in this kind of gray
area we call the goldilocks zone
anywhere from 15 to kind of a 7 8 range
the greens were really good right
consistent throughout the day good speed
good firmness
they withstood the amount of traffic
for the amount of daily play well um so
that was kind of the goldilocks zone and
so after looking at that data the end of
2018
2019 dave said okay i'm gonna make some
changes here the first thing i need to
do is maybe get some better drainage in
these screens let's get some more sand
in there pull out some organic matter
hopefully that will reduce
these big
changes these big spikes in growth after
rainfall
events
and the second thing you did is okay i'm
going to use clipping volume when i go
out for my fertilizer or plant growth
regulator application
i'm going to look at that clipping
volume data
and adjust it accordingly
so okay if i'm seeing a lot of growth
hey i might up my pgr rate and decrease
my fertilizer rate because i don't need
to grow more i need to grow less
so as you can see 2019 just a year after
collecting that clipping volume data
much more consistent
growth on this fifth grade which
translated to consistent playing
conditions
on the fifth green a couple spikes here
and there but overall a lot more time
spent in that goldilocks zone and it's
something he's kept up with and
kept an eye on over the years
because it's really helped him dial in
uh those those nutrient management
practices on his greens
so green's obviously the place to kind
of implement that
uh rick slattery and i are talking about
well okay you know can you do this on
bigger areas right fairways or tees
most people are probably not
collecting clippings in buckets on those
surfaces maybe some of you are
most people probably returning those
clippings
you know just an idea that that you
could do out on those surfaces is
measure height
uh this this data is from my home lawn
right every time i go out and mow which
is which is not often enough
i take a height measurement of the grass
and then calculate essentially the
growth per day since my last cut
and this might be something you could
start to use on your fairway areas to
dial in nutrient management practices
there
again for for plain consistency's sake
and maybe that helps you save fertilizer
over time which on those big fairway
areas is going to add up to a lot more
than
say a green area
so we're almost
down to our last
nutrient management bmp here which is
writing it out what do i mean by writing
it out these are nutrient management
plans
only 14 adoption based on our surveys
um so this again i was talking about
earlier we had a lot of conversation
with superintendents
around okay why don't you have a
nutrient management plan what's that
about first thing i would get is uh you
know that the point to the old noggin
it's all up here i don't need to write
it down i know it
other reasons kind of these barriers for
producing a nutrient management plan on
a piece of paper
uh too much time and that's completely
understandable and then also you don't
know where to start
there's a couple resources online that
talk about a nutrient management plan
but
i can certainly relate to those those
two right taking too much time and not
knowing where to start
um so you know in our solutions we have
to start addressing these barriers right
so okay why is it important to write it
down as opposed to just having it in
your head right and i would say the
first thing and most important i think
for a lot of superintendents
is that it's going to help us stay one
step ahead of regulations as an industry
all right we have to show some
initiative on our part
that hey we're writing down our nutrient
management plans
and that maybe you don't have to
legislate um you know fertilizer use
through proposed bills
sometimes which have some science-based
science-based recommendations sometimes
not
um if more than 14 percent of our
industry had a nutrient management plan
maybe they wouldn't consider
some of these proposed
bills
so i would say if more of us had a
document that explained how exactly we
fertilize our golf courses
that there would be less inclination
on the regulatory side to
um to prohibit sales or applications of
nitrogen or any sort of fertilizer
another thing i think is really
important and may be understated is
communicating with ownership
right words matter and we talk to our
owners or
greens committees or boards
and that's all well and good but
sometimes it doesn't come out how you
want it to sometimes people selectively
remember things you say and misinterpret
them
if you can write that down on a piece of
paper you control your message right you
control what people are going to read
about how you apply nutrients on the
golf course
and it's it's everlasting right you can
always refer them back to that i think
it streamlines communication makes it
more simple
so there are two reasons to uh to write
it out from that aspect and the final
one is is you may actually learn
something
when you're writing down a nutrient
management plan maybe you're forced to
think about okay why do i do this with
my fertilizers it's just because i've
always have done it or is there a reason
behind it
so maybe you learn something while
you're you're writing down your nutrient
management plan or maybe you actually
commit to something
there's a lot of research that says hey
when we
write something down as a commitment
we're more likely to carry out that goal
there's these pledges down on long
island for homeowners to
reduce nitrogen pollution
you can think of your nutrient
management plan documenting that as a
commitment
and maybe that helps you
kind of solidify some of the practices
you do out there
but as to the you know taking time
component where do i start component
frank and rick and i are thinking about
this and said hey you know what if we
just created a template and it was a
fill in the blank and it was easy it's
this kind of turbo tax version of a
nutrient management plan
it's
it addresses those concerns you know
because it's all right in front of you
it takes less time you don't need to go
searching around for what data to
include
um so that's what we did um on our
website now we have uh
we have this pdf that's fillable right
you just click in yes no there's a
couple of
of areas you've got to enter some
information
but we've tried to make creating a
nutrient management plan simple and easy
and this template is a way to do that
so just to you know example here we've
got some again we're carrying out these
par birdie eagle concepts right so
we're asking you do you do these things
not that you have to do them all but we
have those par birdies and eagles right
next to them to kind of underscore hey
okay this is an advanced concept
this is one we think everybody should do
so hopefully people check that out
i'll include the link
below our youtube video here we'll send
it out in the chat
but this is a really easy way to create
a nutrient management plan we call it a
worksheet
and once you fill it out then it's a
plan
becomes
something you can give to people
and will give them all the information
they need regarding your nutrient
management plan
so uh you know those are the par birdies
and eagles of our
nutrient management plan section
all right finishing off here measuring
growth and writing it out really
important
um
so i think i'll stop there and we'll see
if we have any questions from the
audience or uh from you frank
yeah thanks carl you know
i i get the pleasure of you know talking
this through with you all the time so i
have
you know
a number of clarifying questions
and i guess
it begins with what we learned in the
survey and i and i think you said it and
i just want to make sure that
you and i and rick our colleague also
you know sort of are
are clear about this um
i would say when it comes to
fertilization most people we talked to
said oh yeah you know i have yeah
i have a plan
i know how i fertilize i know what i do
i'm like all right i don't really know
just you know like i go out about a
tenth of a pound a week or
you know you get something particularly
on greensbreak and about oh i haven't
put a pound on in two years right so you
get this variety of things can you take
a minute
and it's really what you ended with
can you take a minute and say you know
what's the difference between what we
think we are doing
as an industry
and what we think we need to be doing
you know you really covered it in a
broad way i wonder if
you know you can narrow it down to say
here's what we've sort of learned you
are doing when it comes to this sort of
nutrient management planning idea
thinking through what you're doing and
you you know you went through it in a
really granular way about the various
levels that they can do it what's the
difference between what's in your head
and what gets in this plan
yeah i think and you mentioned it there
a little bit frank that some people may
be fertilizing and they may be employing
all these bmps i talked about today and
they might be people who go out and
advocate for the turf industry and say
hey yeah i'm doing this and a lot of
other people are doing it
when we get these representative samples
of surveys this random data
we get a true kind of indication of what
people are doing and the reality is
is there's there's piecemeal things
going on some people may be actually
applying
according to growth and they don't even
know it right this is a feel-based thing
and you know a lot of people who tell me
oh you know feel
we'll go out and we'll we'll be feeling
the grass and let's say hey you know
it's growing a little bit too much i
don't need more fertilizer and they
don't even know they're fertilizing
based on growth
and they might not even be able to
communicate that to people they may just
say hey i'm a field guy
but writing that down is really key
because then that reinforces yes you are
in fact
fertilizing based on growth and some
people on the other hand may just have a
schedule and they may think yeah i've
done all this due diligence and i've and
i've scheduled all these things out and
i've talked with a bunch of people
but they're actually not as reactive to
some of these growth things so on a
piece of paper they have a nutrient
management plan and that's really good
but hey you know okay let's let's think
more about growth and let's be a little
bit less you know a slave to that
schedule and that workbook um so i think
you know like you're saying frank
there's
there's a lot of things that in your
head sometimes we would like we like
them so much we want you to write them
down
because sometimes they don't come out
when you're talking about them and then
in other cases people might have a lot
of things written down
but not things that necessarily we would
recommend uh in a you know eagle version
of a nutrient management plan
one of the things i like that you've
done very successfully is say you know
obviously this is a water quality
pollution prevention project you know
we're starting to
we're trying to bring some precision and
specificity
to the way we fertilize and manage
nutrients on these large expanses of
land you know that are used for
recreational purposes you know and we
call them golf courses right um
how when you think it through
do you generally think that things that
are really good for playability are
probably really good for water quality
protection
i i think so i think
you know the tenant you will always hear
firm and fast that lends itself to less
nutrient use right maybe it's it's more
the brown color you know the gold is
good color i know the usj with pioneers
many years back
um those sorts of things inherently are
kind of towards the lower nutrient
management end
um so there is some crossover there but
i i think also you know talking about
traffic high traffic areas i'm
completely fine with saying you need
more fertilizer in that rough area if
you have single rider carts um and
sometimes that sounds contradictory
because we said hey one of our bmps is
not to apply fertilizer and rough but
there is that you know there's there's
these changes there's these niches that
hey in this situation i do think you
need fertilizer here and being able to
say that because of the concepts we're
creating going by growth going by
traffic
it doesn't really you know so your
question about
nutrients and playability
in most cases i think lower nutrients
probably better for playability but
there are some cases where hey i think
you need to go higher on nitrogen to
reduce dollar spots to reduce
anthracnose so that you're not spraying
pesticides we'll get to the pest
management portion of this later but
sometimes fertilizer in place of
pesticides is a good thing um yeah and
that's the transition that's the perfect
transition i was looking for because
traffic is obviously a past a stress if
you will and if if left uh unmanaged uh
leads to soil compaction and turf
thinning and soil erosion wheat invasion
and then pesticide use and and you know
that's we can take it out of the rough
into the fairway you know you look at
the amount of divots or the traffic in a
landing area or maybe you got a bunker
jutting out where the the whole fairway
is pinched and everybody's going in the
same spot and then you get the dollar
spot and the pythium and the brown patch
in those areas where
if you could target
some nitrogen use in that place you'd
probably have fewer problems if you
could target so cultivation in those
places you would probably have fewer
problems and being able to maintain you
know full turf cover
for a lot of the places that we visited
in in our in our surveys you know these
smaller scale focused operations as the
usga would say
um you know if 100 turf cover is really
good you know that's what they should be
striving for a 100 turf cover that gives
you a playing surface and i think i
would be remiss if i didn't sort of
bring rick in to say hey
you know just remember
there's ways of of doing this that are
more responsible and simple
and practical and makes sense it's not
just a couple of academics saying oh
let's get satellite data and do it this
way you know rick always tells us hey it
can be simple it can be practical and
you can really make a difference uh by
doing that
yeah and to end on that note i think
frank you know we're talking about these
properties and eagles it's important i'm
not expecting we aren't expecting
everybody to do all of this right we're
not expecting every facility to go out
there and do this gps usga data
but having those you know the
bmps that are step away from that right
just observing keeping down in notes
rick has a nice little note that he
would keep it a journal every year
observing things about his golf course
on a weekly basis on a daily basis
um so you know okay you don't have that
specific data but hey you've got your
observations and i would call that data
i would call your observations when it's
in a notebook and it's written down
that's data if it's just in your head
and say yeah three years ago i think
this worked
i'm not gonna buy that as data but um
you know so so the end goal here what
i'm talking about is i don't expect
everybody to be eagerly in everything on
these on these infographic posters but
you know get your cars in order right be
a consistent player as zach johnson
let's par a bunch of holes then let's
figure out how to birdie the par 5's
right bertie when we can um i think
those are the important concepts so and
that's the perfect place to end carl
thank you for a wonderful presentation i
do think we did by your impetus create
the par birdie eagle concept and i do
think we expect people to meet par i
don't think it's unreasonable and we
really tried to make par
you know it's not a robert trent jones
bmp process you know it's not a
difficult par it should be an easy par
uh and and and then we want to give you
shots for bertie and the eagles as your
resources and time allow so thanks again
carl really appreciate that and big
shout out to rick slattery who you know
we wouldn't be really doing this without
him uh keeping us honest and being our
compass for you know how we get these
things implicated so thank you all for
joining us for this uh second in a
series of bmp webinars and we'll look
forward to seeing you at the next bunch
thanks a lot
take care
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu